So, we have looked at individual developers and past bugs,
at complexity, at tests, at team structure, and at the problem domain.
Developers get assigned to tasks that are hard in the first place,
and tasks that are hard call for more bugs.
That is, also more past bugs.
Also, more testing.
All of this leads us to the domain as being the most important factor
in determining where bugs actually come from.
If the domain changes frequently, this will lead to more bugs.
If the domain is complex in itself, such as JavaScript or in eclipse the compiler,
this will lead to more bugs.
If the domain is not well-defined--
for instance, because the team cannot agree on what to do--
then this also calls for more bugs.
What we can do, though, is by looking at past bugs,
identify which parts of the domain and possibly other influences
correlate with past bugs.
This may give us a handle on how to avoid such mistakes in the future.